Mireya Villarreal is also in Hidalgo
speaking to people on both sides of the
border wall debate maria good morning
well good morning the wall that they're
planning to build right here in Texas
would not only divide the land but
potentially divide the people that are
living here on one side of this debate
we spoke with a border patrol agent
that's working without getting paid
because of this shutdown and says he
supports the president's plan on the
other side as a family that lives along
the river they say they are planning to
fight the government to keep a wall just
like this from ripping through their
land see the little building over there
with a tin roof right all the way up to
there Bedelia Rodriguez grew up on this
property her grandmother bought more
than 60 years ago it sits right along
the Rio grab that's Mexico right across
I don't mean we have we saw people
coming over it was people that were good
people it was people that were seeking
asylum for their children but now the
roughly 64 acres stretch of land could
soon be in the path of president Trump's
border wall
who is this Patrol and that's pretty
regular huh
that's pretty regular now her brother
and sister now own the land they rent
some of the property to tenants who
built small houses and trailers here now
it was 65 acres I have four tenants that
pay me a lot yearly basis in that's how
you make your income yes right right the
family fears the wall will drive them
away it's very first why the family's
property is located within a hundred
four mile stretch of land where the
government is planning to build a wall
the government could use a process known
as eminent domain to seize the land with
compensation from private owners like
Rodriguez's brother he argues the wall
won't stop people from illegally
crossing it won't help people steal you
know that a desperate yeah when you're
desperate you do anything we need border
security we do n and I've been part of
that border security is is a barrier
Chris Cabrera is a 17-year Border Patrol
veteran who's on the front lines working
without pay and supports president
Trump's wall anytime you build anything
in the United States when you build a
highway it goes through people's land I
mean it's just that's just how it works
the Texas Civil Rights Project is
representing this family and others
trying to fight the government
neighbors have received an offer from
the government so far but this family
has not they say it doesn't matter
because even if they did they would not
take it because it means splitting apart
their family's history
viata it's been great watching your
reports and the real-life ramifications
that this debate really has created
thank you